in the middle of easter i just wanted to
take
a little bit of time to acknowledge and
wish everyone a
a happy easter but particularly i really
want to acknowledge the effort and the
time and the commitment that has gone in
uh to making this a safe and secure
place
over this last two weeks and for the
commitment that's going to go in for the
next
two weeks to civil defense workers to
health workers to supermarket workers
to delivery personnel everyone that is
in that
essential worker space each time they go
out of their home they're putting
themselves at risk for us
and i just say thank you each and every
one of you
for the job that you are doing and
continue to do and i wish
you all the very best to the residents
of uh district i also want to say thank
you very much for the commitment you put
in to take this
this message that we have had nationally
and
very seriously and i think looking at
the the numbers
of positive covert patients in our
district
really illustrates the fact that we have
taken that seriously
uh to stay at two for as long as we have
uh
is is a tribute uh to the commitment
that you have put in so thank you
very very much for
so as as the sun is shining and
there's work to be done uh i just want
to wish
all residents um all the best for the
rest of easter
all the best for the rest of the two
weeks that we've got to go
being locked down so from my bubble on
river road to yours and stay safe
and for goodness sake stay at home